fleeing on foot carrying all their
worldly possessions the highway out of
quarantine Bogota has become dotted with
hundreds of homeless hungry Venezuelans
attempting to walk back to their
battered country boots Alice and her
family worked as street vendors but with
the lockdown they ran out of money and
ended on the streets there was no one
left to sell to how were we supposed to
survive the police even prohibited us
from being outside
we live hand-to-mouth day by day how can
we pay the daily rent how can we eat in
recent years more than 4 million
Venezuelans fled to other South American
countries escaping the economic collapse
in Venezuela some had managed to earn a
meager but decent living like the Ries
who worked in a car wash leaving was an
agonizing decision there's nothing left
to do here we lost our jobs and we can't
count on getting help from the
government until two weeks ago when the
lockdown started Venezuelan migrants in
difficulty had access to some form of
assistance but since then shelters
migrant centers and soup kitchens have
all closed leaving them with no help at
all
the government has increased the number
of cash transfers to some struggling
families but it's not enough
Bogut as mayor said that at least for
now temporary shelters being built in
the city were exclusively for vulnerable
Colombians the doors of Catholic relief
organizations are closed with no
official date for reopening father will
frown alaya says the fear of contagion
and the excessive number of people in
need
left them with no other option no we
don't have the resources nor the space
to deal with this pressure we're saying
that the mayor and the government are
passing responsibility to one another
because the number of people our need
are simply too high back in the highway
there Louise stopped to catch a breath
and firm up their bags they estimate
there will take them 15 days to get to
the border they know the situation back
home will be equally tough but at least
they say they'll have a roof over their
heads and their family nearby to help as
much as they can
Allison Trump et al Jazeera Bogota